hello everybody good morning to you
there's a new warning that has now
become the norm for children as young as
nine to run drugs for gangs in England a
report by the commission on young lives
found that they're getting lured into
drug dealing and violence with thousands
of young people groomed harmed and even
killed
the commission is now calling on the
government to treat the exploitation of
children as seriously as it does
terrorism as our home editor Jason
Farrell reports
bursting with life Leah died because of
one bad decision but also from what's
been described today as a national
problem hidden in plain sight
the first Leah's mum realized it was
when Medics were trying to resuscitate
her daughter I knew as soon as I got
there there was police there was other
nurses around and I knew just by their
reaction it wasn't good they had their
heads down
Leah had overdosed on MDMA whilst out
with friends she lived here in
northallerton Rishi sunat constituency
which doesn't look like it has a youth
drug problem but does and it's often
children who are selling the drugs
Tammy's teenage son supplied the MDMA
that killed Leah she doesn't want us to
give his name but he got sucked into
county lines dealing from the age of 14
and Tammy says for three years she
couldn't get support to get him out
three days before Leah died the police
were in my house I was asking for help
and if there is something would have
happened those three days or when he was
14 he should not have gone to jail and
Leo would be here
this is exactly the problem identified
by today's report from the commission on
young lives one of the things we get we
got told time and time again was that
you know when a parent found the
horrific burner phone in the child's
bedroom or a knife or some cash they'd
ring up Social Services or they'd ring
up the police but no one could help them
Leah's mum thinks people who deal to
teenagers should get tougher sentences
but recognizes the boy who supplied
Leah's drugs was himself exploited he
was groomed he was groomed and to do
this
um I don't think he's a horrible person
do you think he's a victim yeah
100 percent
a report by the commission on young
lives today recommended a sure start for
teenagers bringing support and
intervention together in local hubs
backed up by what it calls an army of
Youth workers and schools remaining open
during school holidays and weekends as
safe places for children along with an
additional 1 billion pounds investment
to combat teenage mental health problems
with money raised from social media
companies
it used to be the case you'd have 11 12
13 year olds who were running delivering
the drugs now that's going down 9 10 11
but also where you've got young
teenagers 13 14 actually heading up
county lines delivering drugs that cost
the country you know running a business
here in a very ruthless way
previously we've met gangs running
county lines looking to exploit children
this is what I give to the people and
the little kids they all go out for me
and the report says with the cost of
living crisis more children are easy
prey research by the YMCA published
earlier this year found across the
country the annual spend on Child
Services has fallen by 74 percent in the
last decade and what this report is
calling for is more investment
there in the inner cities or the
Yorkshire Countryside reversing those
Trends won't be easy it's not just about
let's throw this money here it's about
how we're going to do it who's going to
be trained on it
you know and where are they going to get
the social workers and the youth workers
because nobody wants to come into Health
and Social Care at the minute
the report argues that investing in
preventing children from being exploited
in the long term would save huge costs
within the criminal justice system as
well as preventing heartache for
families Jason Farrell Sky News
well the policing Minister Chris philp
joins me now a very good morning to you
thanks so much for coming in good
morning let's just start with that
report
um children as young as nine running
drugs for gangs thousands of young
people in England being groomed harmed
or even killed how has this been allowed
to happen and get worse under your watch
well uh I've been in the job for about a
week this is yeah this is a matter
that's of deep concern it has been for
some years so in 2019 three years ago a
whole initiative was launched to tackle
this County Line's problem whereas your
report really powerfully set out
Children very young children often are
being groomed and exploited there are
four priority areas where money has been
invested that's London uh greater
Manchester merseyside and the West
Midlands in particular 145 million
pounds was put against this task and as
a result of that 2 400 county lines
operations have been dismantled and
there have been eight thousand arrests
so a huge amount of work has been done
here the there's a coordination Center
to make sure that we're coordinating
nationally because obviously these
county lines by by their very nature
cross police force areas for example you
might have a gang in London for instance
running uh drugs down to the South Coast
to Coastal communities so it runs across
police force boundaries that's why the
coordination is so important there's a
lot of work going on here over the last
three years in particular both with
money and with police officer resource
that is delivering results those 8 000
arrests are making a real difference but
they're clearly is a lot more work to do
well yes I mean you say results but
these are startling facts that children
that young getting involved and caught
up in these gangs and the report says
that there are already huge stresses on
over stretched Services they they
suggest that any return to austerity
would be a gift to those who exploit
children yet we have warnings of course
from the chancellor that spending cuts
are needed to balance the book so will
the necessary budgets be protected in
this spending review well only to wait
and see what the chancellor says on the
17th of November but I would expect as
the chancellor just makes his decisions
in the coming weeks the critical
services will get uh will get protected
uh that's certainly a case I'll be
making only to wait and see what the
chancellor sets out in his statement in
a couple of weeks time okay what about
the other suggestions the report says
that young people and their families
should be helped out of poverty
beginning with the up rating of family
benefits in line with inflation ending
the two child benefit cap and the
extension of free School meals to all
families receiving Universal Credit
given the severity of the situation will
the government commit to that well let's
just think about the action that's been
taken already to help families with
children and without particularly on
lower income so we've had this energy
crisis families have received families
on Lower incomes this year are receiving
1 200 pounds in help some of that money
is being received this month as we speak
the energy price guarantee is protecting
families from bills that could have been
as high as five or six thousand pounds
these with specific cases that the
report is asking for and when it comes
to people on Lower incomes you know
we've significantly increased the
minimum wage it's gone from 593 an hour
under labor up to nine pounds 50 now
we've lifted all the tax thresholds so
people on Lower earnings pay no income
tax and no National Insurance whatsoever
so a huge range of measures particularly
designed to help people on Lower incomes
and I'm sure those things are helpful
but what the report is calling for for
an uprating of family benefits in line
with inflation ending the two-child
benefit cap and the extension of free
School meals to all families receiving
Universal Credit you can't guarantee
that will happen well I can't because
the chancellor obviously is going to set
out his plans on November 17th he'll
have heard that I'm sure along with
other ideas other people are putting
forward as well and you know we'll find
out in a couple of weeks um what his
plans are well we will indeed there's a
lot of focus on that and I want to talk
about the economy a little bit because
um your old boss Liz trust you worked in
the Treasury under her she said that a
recession wasn't inevitable but we're
now looking at the longest recession in
a century and the decisions that you
made are partly to blame for that aren't
they well I think countries around the
world are facing enormous economic
challenges it's not just this country as
the bank of England said yesterday the
European Central Bank have made similar
comments uh JP Morgan uh have said the
United States of America the U.S has
similar challenges the IMF said
one-third of global economies are going
to be going into recession so this is a
global phenomena we're not immune to
that but the UK has a specific problem
doesn't it and in fact asked about
whether this meltdown was down to Global
factors yesterday the bank of England
Governor Andrew Bailey said I don't
really think that's the case he also has
said that he believed that the mini
budget had damaged the UK standing
internationally you were in the room
when the decisions were made about the
mini budget he's kind of blaming you
isn't he well the decisions uh on around
the mini budget were made by the former
Chancellor and the former prime minister
yeah I was on the treasury team that's
right but the decisions as you would
expect were made by the chance counselor
the previous Chancellor in the previous
prime minister who are no longer in post
if you look at the movements to the
currency and to government bonds that
happened around that time the negative
moves that happened four or five weeks
ago and those numbers have now returned
pretty much to the levels they were
before what we now need to do is uh make
sure that we're on an even Keel the new
Chancellor is doing that already and the
new prime minister Rishi sunak is
someone who successfully guided our
economy through covid we came through
covid uh you know we now have the lowest
unemployment we've had for 48 years
according to the budget an incredible
projection but let's think about where
we're starting from we've got the lowest
unemployment for 48 years because Rishi
sunaka's Chancellor guided us through
kovid and I think he'll guide us through
this crisis very well also in terms of
GDP growth um you know last year not
just last year but also this year
according to the IMF the UK had the
highest GDP growth in the G7 not just
last year but this year as well so we
are starting from a good position but in
common with Western economies developed
economies around the world there are
challenges but we can meet them bit of
recession for for eight quarters
whatever position you start in that's a
pretty bad place to end up and Andrew
Bailey did say that we were hours from
Financial meltdown following the mini
budget are you quite embarrassed to have
been involved in that do you have any
regrets do you feel like you want to
apologize well I think Liz truss has
already apologized and sure would you
would you like to say well although I am
along with other people work was a
minister in that government at the time
the decisions those decisions were taken
principally by the former prime minister
to a lesser extent by the former
Chancellor and she has apologized for
that and then neither of them are in
office
um any longer what I think we're doing
now or Jeremy Hunt and we've seen like
are doing is making sure the country is
on an even Keel and in the same way that
Rishi guided our economy very
successfully through covid you know as I
said we've got the lowest unemployment
for 48 years an incredible achievement
it's half the level that labor left
behind you know I think you'll do the
same thing through this Global crisis
that we're entering if you think about
inflation that is a global crisis you
know uh Eurozone inflation is 10 in
Germany it's 12 in Holland it's 14 so
these are Global problems okay let's
talk about the UK um you talk about the
chancellor being all about sound public
finances we know that cuts are on the
way there are reports this morning that
the new nuclear plant in Suffolk
sizewell C is under review can you
confirm that the case no I'm afraid I
don't know anything about about whether
that is or is not under consideration uh
you know my job in the home office is
looking after policing
um so I can't I can't comment on that at
all I really just don't know
um we'll find out on November 17th um
what the plans are okay well a quick
question then about capital gains tax
the the telegraph reporting of possible
changes any notification of the
direction they might be looking at I'm
afraid I just don't know the the
treasury will be making their plans I
don't know what those are and we'll just
have to wait and see what gets announced
on the 17th okay well let's stick to
your brief and which is of course
policing as you say uh Wednesday's
damning report found evidence a poor
decision making in police vetting
inconsistent handling of misconduct
cases uh your 2019 Manifesto set targets
20 000 Police recruitment
cutting Corners to meet those targets no
I don't think so we're on track to meet
that Target by the way we've hired 15
000 of the twenty thousand and we're on
track to deliver all 20 000 extra police
by March of next year by sort of four or
five months time uh three and a half
billion pounds extra was provided to
police forces over that period the 2019
to 2022 period uh when those officers
were being recruited to pay not just for
their additional salaries but also for
the uh the support and the
infrastructure including vetting that
goes around that which makes it
particularly
um sort of disappointing that these very
serious failings were identified by the
inspectors report published a day or two
ago there were 43 recommendations in
that report three of those were for the
home office that we will Implement
um pretty much immediately or certainly
urgently the other 40 recommendations
with police forces
um the npcc uh Chief Martin Hewitt has
said they will act on all of those that
is my expectation as police Minister and
I'm going to work with police to make
sure those are implemented as quickly as
possible okay let's talk about Manson
shall we the processing center in Kent
can we get an update on the number of
people that are in that processing
center now how many are there and how
many have been moved out well so uh over
a thousand people have been moved out in
the last uh week or so so a substantial
number uh since the beginning of
September when the current Home
Secretary took office I think a total of
9 000 people this is people coming in
and out the whole time 9 000 people have
left I think numbers have a very
substantially reduced in the course of
the last week and they're investing in
creating uh more facilities there and
better facilities to address some of the
concerns that have been raised but where
are they gone I mean we've got reports
of a second group of migrants left
stranded at Victoria Coach Station well
they've mostly gone to hotels they're
about four and a half thousand uh extra
hotels have been procured but what about
these people that have been stranded yes
there were two groups of people and what
I've been told by the uh people on the
immigration side of home office is that
both groups of people had told
immigration officials at manston they
had addresses to go to so friends and
family obviously that turned out
subsequently not to be the case but the
information that Homeless officials had
understood was they had places to go to
because many of the people do have
friends and family in the UK already so
this was a mistake uh yeah clearly that
without understanding was was not
accurate quite how that misunderstanding
arose maybe it was Lost in Translation I
don't know um but clearly they have now
been looked after okay as a former
immigration compliance Minister do you
accept that manston is not legally
compliant now I'm not sure I do accept
that significant improvements have been
made uh recently we had similar
challenges over the Napier site in
folkestone and we made improvements
there to make it compliant so um you
know but we should keep in mind that you
know there is a huge challenge we've got
here with I mean about 40 000 people so
far have illegally entered the UK so far
this year on small boats and that is a
huge operational challenge it's very
very hard to deal with that now these
these Journeys are totally unnecessary
because France obviously is a safe
country with a well-functioning Asylum
system these Journeys don't need to be
made no one is fleeing war in France
these Journeys should not be made to get
be getting made in the first place well
many people would argue they need more
legal routes to come in and well let's
talk about the Asylum Seekers that's
right so so first of all France has a
well-functioning Asylum system secondly
the predominant nationality the largest
single nationality is Albanian Albania
is a safe and civilized country you
don't need to leave Albania uh for your
safety it's a safe country in terms of
safe and legal routes we have a lot of
safe and legal routes let me give you a
couple of examples you know we've taken
very briefly 150 000 ukrainians uh 20
000 syrians when there was the war there
23 000 Afghans over a hundred thousand
people from Hong Kong fleeing the
Chinese Communist party where a lot of
safe and legal routes we've been very
generous to people who are in genuine
need the groups I just mentioned being
Prime examples of that but we can't
accept and frankly can't even handle
operationally because the numbers are so
large are people making these dangerous
and unnecessary Journeys across the
channel from France a safe country and
that is why quite radical action is
needed legislatively uh to make sure
that our International treaty
obligations aren't being domestically
interpreted okay in a way that makes it
impossible to run our immigrated
immigration systems that we will have to
have another time or conversation to
have another time but I do want to just
come back to this question of whether or
not Manson is legally compliant Robert
generic your colleague at tall Sky News
this week he expected Manson to be
returned to a well-functioning and
legally compliant site very rapidly the
implication being that it's not
currently legally compliant a lot of
changes have been made in the course of
this week I think Robert has been down
there at least once and possibly twice I
think he's going down again on on Sunday
so significant changes how soon will it
be made before it's legally well I don't
accept the premise that it's not legally
compliant today a lot of changes have
been made even in the last few days
since you spoke to Robert on this chair
I think a few days ago
yeah Wednesday night I think it was okay
well Christopher we're out of time but
thanks very much indeed for coming in
thank you
so let's take a look now at the front
pages of the morning papers uh this will
hurt that's on the front of the Metro
after the big Bank of England rates rise
and the expectation of a long recession
to come
similar sentiments in the express which
says there are stormy times ahead
the eye describes what's to come as a
toxic shock for millions of people as
the country's economy as a whole
and the times tells us the rise is aimed
at heading off the worrying increase in
inflation that we've been seeing in
recent months
and the financial times says that
despite the latest rise the bank doesn't
think that future Rises will be as high
as the markets have feared
so that's the front pages of morning's
newspapers let's now tell you what's
still to come here on this show I'm
going to be speaking to Celine Saxby
who's the MP who has raised concerns
with the home office that plans to house
Asylum seekers in hotels in her
constituency
or speak to an expert in infectious
disease about the case of a British man
who's thought to have had covered longer
than anybody else and survived
and then the next hour I'll be joined by
Jonathan Reynolds the shadow business
secretary so lots to come here on the
show
meanwhile though as we've been telling
you the government is facing a series of
challenges over the way that it's
dealing with Asylum Seekers arriving in
the UK from claims of the rape of
children and people being kept in
appalling conditions to criticism over
the home secretary's visit to manston
and Dover well Matthew Thompson is at
the Manson Immigration Center for us
this morning so just yesterday of course
we saw the Home Secretary visit there
Matthew
we certainly did and she didn't take any
questions from journalists she arrived
in a military helicopter a chinook that
took her the mere 15 miles from Dover to
here at manston and that raised a few
eyebrows why she would go to those
lengths
certainly a number of immigration
Charities have criticized her for doing
that on board a military helicopter
saying that it sort of it looked as if
she was leaning into her controversial
words the other day about an invasion on
the coast but the home office is very
strongly briefing that she took that
helicopter Journey because she was
actually flying over the coastline to
observe some of the work that the Border
force is doing to protect the coastline
and stop or tackle these Small Boat
Crossings because there were no
questions asked to the Home Secretary
when she was here we got a handout of
her comments and what she promised to do
was improve some of the services here
Medical Services bedding things like
that and also the government confirming
that the latest numbers they say are
around 2 700 left in the center behind
me that's dying from a peak of around 4
000 but let's bear in mind that it was
only ever intended to be set up for some
1600 migrants and even then for the
money to be here for 24 hours there are
stories of migrants having spent weeks
in the camp behind me and that's what
leads us to this legally contentious
territory you were just discussing with
the minister a moment ago two Charities
knowledge attention action and bail for
immigration detainees have written
pre-action letters to the home office at
warning that the Detention of people in
camps like this particularly menston for
more than 24 hours is they say illegal
the home officer said that it will
respond to those in due course and it
also comes as we've heard now two coach
loads the minister confirming there of
migrants seem to have been abandoned in
the middle of the street at Victoria
Coach Station in London many of them
having having to spend the night
sleeping on the streets and the home of
us now says as Chris philp was just
telling you that that's because there
was a misunderstanding that these people
had told the home office that they had
people to stay with and people to
collect them but I think what it shows
you is still the sense of Crisis that's
engulfing the center here at Manson even
as the government assures us it's doing
everything in its power to get on top of
the situation
okay Matthew thanks very much indeed
now China's president Xi Jinping has
told the German Chancellor Olaf scholz
their two countries should work together
during times of turmoil the leaders met
in Beijing this morning he's the first
Western leader to visit the country
since the covid-19 pandemic well let's
bring in our Asia correspondent Helen
Smith he's in the Chinese Capital Forest
now so Helena what's the reaction being
then to this visit
foreign
well I think Olaf Schultz is sending a
very very clear message by coming here
to Beijing today and his message
unequivocally is that an isolated China
is really no good for anyone he could
not have picked a more beautiful day to
come here it is absolutely stunning the
sky is blue the sun is shining the
German flags have been flying next to
the Chinese flags in Tiananmen Square
just across the way where the leaders
are meeting but be under No Illusion
this has been an extremely tricky visit
both logistically and politically
logistically China is still in the midst
of its zero covert agenda the German
delegation have had to be bubbled they
can't stay the night everyone who's
coming into contact with them is have to
be quarantined afterwards and
politically as well remember this comes
just after the pandemic he is the first
leader from the G7 from Europe to come
since the pandemic a time where this
country has been increasingly isolated
and it also comes just after the 20th
party Congress here in China where she's
power president XI was given a an
unprecedented third term his power very
much much Consolidated and increasingly
sort of autocratic ruling system here
and it comes at a time where tensions
between China and the West have been
very very high so it is complex in that
context on the agenda will absolutely be
the war in Ukraine uh China's still an
incredibly powerful voice in that
Dynamic it hasn't equivocally condemned
or um or sort of supported the war in
Ukraine but its position could be
extremely important to the west and also
trade the kind of Financial and economic
interlinking between Germany and China
that runs very very deep and Germany
certainly burned by the sudden sanctions
on Russia and what that's the the
implications that's caused sort of
economically across Europe so so many
many important issues on the agenda but
I think importantly what gen what Olaf
Schultz is trying to sort of say in the
symbolism of this visit is that China
was an important player geopolitically
economically and negotiating with China
being seen to work with China will be
more important more valuable than
allowing it to become increasingly more
isolated
hello Nan thanks very much indeed
now the former Pakistan prime minister
Imran Khan has had surgery after being
shot at a protest March one person has
been arrested
claimed the attack was an attempted
assassination and highlights concerns
about political instability in the
country
our Asia correspondent Cordelia Lynch
was at the scene of the shooting and had
spoken to Mr Khan shortly before the
incident
the only terrorist threat for us is the
government
and the handlers does it worry the
prospect of violence
well I'm confident I'm confident that
and I've been on the road for six months
now
what I've seen I'm confident that I will
be able to direct it through elections
the government has no choice but to hold
elections sooner or later and I think
it's only a matter of time
Twitter is expected to start Mass
layoffs today as the company's new boss
Elon Musk moves to cut costs staff are
told not to come into the social media
Giants offices this morning they'll
receive an email later letting them know
if they still have a job our U.S
correspondent Martha Kellner has the
latest
I was outside the Twitter headquarters
in San Francisco last week when it was
confirmed that Elon Musk had completed
the Takeover of the company speaking to
staff there this is what they were
fearing and in many if not all cases
this is what they were expecting that
there would be Mass layoffs at the
organization and it seems that that is
now coming to pass this memo sent to
staff this evening saying team in an
effort to place Twitter on a healthy
path we will go through the difficult
process of reducing our Global Workforce
this action is unfortunately necessary
to ensure the company's success moving
forward now this memo outlines exactly
what will happen it tells staff that at
9am local time in San Francisco so
that's 4 P.M UK time staff will receive
an email if their position is to remain
intact if there's to be no change to
their job they'll receive that email
through their official Twitter email
account if they're to lose their job
they'll receive that email through their
personal account this continues an
incredibly controversial first week in
charge for Elon Musk the richest man in
the world now in charge of one of the
world's most influential communication
platforms you also have a speculation
about what's going to happen with
content moderation and will there be a
return for the former president Donald
Trump to Twitter but first and foremost
you have this weight for staff around 7
500 Twitter staff not sure whether they
will still be in a job after 9am local
time tomorrow
also making the news this morning the
Russian ambassador to the UK has
dismissed claims that his country will
use nuclear weapons in Ukraine in an
interview with Sky News however Andre
Kellen has suggested that the Kremlin
has evidence that Britain was behind a
drone attack on Russia's Black Sea Fleet
in Crimea and now risks escalating the
situation
we perfectly know about participation of
British specialists in training
preparation and execution of players
against the Russian infrastructure and
the Russian Fleet in balexi
the king will today host a reception at
Buckingham Palace ahead of the cop 27
climate Summit in Egypt his majesty will
welcome more than 200 International
Business Leaders marking the end of the
UK's presidency of the conference
Downing Street says Rishi sunak has not
been in office long enough for the
logistics to be arranged for the Monarch
to attend [ __ ] 27.
the prince of Princess of Wales were
upstaged by a young fan in North
Yorkshire from the moment they arrived
at a community Hub in Scarborough the
youngster was determined to meet them
foreign
[Music]
Legacy of today bringing people together
and collaborate technique
well yesterday the couple were visiting
a project called the street which
provides mental health support to
youngsters in the town it's one of the
organizations funded by the couple's own
charity Foundation
now earlier I spoke to policing Minister
Chris philp and asked him about reports
of Asylum Seekers left stranded
wandering the Streets of London without
any onward destination so this is what
he told me
what I've been told by the uh people on
the immigration side of the home office
is that both groups of people had told
uh immigration officials at manston they
had addresses to go to so friends and
family obviously that turned out
subsequently not to be the case but the
the information that uh homeless
officials had understood was they had
places to go to because many of the
people do have friends and family in the
UK already so this was a mistake uh yeah
clearly that without understanding was
was not accurate quite how that
misunderstanding arose maybe it was Lost
in Translation I don't know
um but clearly they have now been looked
after
well our political correspondent Rappel
is here with me in the studio morning to
you still a lot of questions over this
processing center in Kent manston how
much have we learned this morning from
the minister about what's going on there
maybe a little bit he did say over a
thousand people have been moved out of
manston
um this week sort of suggested as well
that maybe it was operating even today
in a legal manner maybe it was compliant
legally again today after Robert gemrick
his colleague in the home office
suggested a couple of days ago that it
wasn't in terms of where people are
going though when they're being taken
from mance and he said yes mainly hotels
but we've had this case or two cases in
fact of groups of people being left at a
train station in central London uh with
no kind of idea of what where they were
going now what Chris philp suggested was
that actually those people had told home
office officials at manston that they
had people to stay with and so sort of
suggesting that actually they had said
that they would be fine when they got to
London
um and and said that maybe there was a
misunderstanding there maybe there was
something that got Lost in Translation I
thought it was interesting as well the
exchange on the economy that you had
with him Chris philp was someone who was
in the treasury he was Chief secretary
to the treasury essentially the
Chancellor's Deputy on the
quasi-quarting and Liz trust so it was
pretty instrumental and right in the
middle of that disastrous mini budget
that we learned yesterday from the bank
of England Governor almost took the
country to financial meltdown not really
wanting to acknowledge any regrets or
apologize but quite uh forcefully
dumping all of the blame at the former
prime minister in the former Chancellor
saying that it was them that made the
decisions that they are no longer in
post and actually the economy is
recovered since they left as well so a
large amount of blame shifting going on
there given he was out on the airwaves
about five weeks ago defending that
economic
um plan clearly there was policing
Minister and as a home office minister
with everything you were discussing with
him there he has substantial new
challenges on his plate now though
absolutely and he said he had great
faith in Rishi scene actor to guide us
through a ruffle moment thanks very much
indeed
so several conservative MPS have
criticized the home office over its
plans to deal with Asylum Seekers
amongst them is Member of Parliament for
North Devon Celine Saxby who's raised
some concerns and suggestions that
people will be housed in hotels in her
constituency and we can speak now to
Celine Saxby so very good morning to you
thanks so much for talking to us so tell
us a little bit about your concerns am I
right in saying you don't want migrants
to stay in hotels in North Devon
good morning no that's not the case at
all and the counselor are very happy to
help the home office as as needed the
situation is is that the hotel which
does now have um Asylum seekers in in
Alpha King was um deemed two weeks ago
by the home office to not be a suitable
place and for Asylum Seekers to go
um and then as of Darkness uh 36 hours
ago it was filled up without any
notification or further discussion with
the council or myself and I think the
concerns are is why was it not suitable
two weeks ago and it is now both for the
local community but also for those
people who are seeking Asylum
what makes it an unsuitable place for
them to go
so originally this was a hotel that was
trading and ilfracum is a lovely tourism
destination and so it's taken out 100
beds out of that local economy and the
whole system seems to be slightly um
backwards that the hotels volunteer
themselves because they can make more
money from the home office than actually
running as a hotel but it damages the
whole ecosystem of the tourism business
in ilfracombe by taking out that many
visitors in the run-up to Christmas so
that was the first concern and then
elfrikim is a um they're even remote
beautiful coastal location and but we do
we are aware it's a long way from a
hospital it doesn't have a train station
and so some of those facilities that
actually people may need if when they're
seeking Asylum are not actually
available there and the counselor myself
felt that a larger connotation nearby if
we were going to be helping would be a
better place for those people to go
well we have heard haven't we in the
last couple of days Council leaders in
Kent uh writing to the Home Secretary
raising their concerns they say the
counties at Breaking Point they've
warned that secondary schools in two
areas have got no places for certain
year groups because of the sudden
arrival of so many Refugee children for
example so it's not fair is it to place
a heavy burden on a few select areas it
needs to be spread more broadly and
including places potentially like
ilfacombe
um it certainly needs to be spread more
broadly but we have bigger towns in
North Devon than ilford [ __ ] that would
be much better place to assist and I
think where the whole process seems to
be going wrong is that councils aren't
being involved in these decisions and
the local councils are well placed to
know where we can accommodate people
safely and securely and that will work
with their local communities and that
doesn't seem to be happening at all
councils are just being completely cut
out of the decision-making process and
then left to sort it out themselves
because Alfred pum also doesn't have
that many school places to be able to
open up its doors um if we need to to
other other families
so are there hotels that would be
suitable in your area that you'd be
happy to to suggest
um I think we'd need to look at whether
it was hotels or whether there are other
types of accommodation as obviously we
do have military bases up there as well
and I think these are the conversations
that just haven't happened that this has
just been railroaded
um and the concern is very much if this
one wasn't suitable two weeks ago why is
it now and who is taking these decisions
so what does that say do you think about
the handling of this situation and the
situation at manston
um I think it's greatly concerning
obviously there does seem to be a link
between the arrival of people in my
constituency and what's going on in
manston
um and it just seems some of these
decisions may have been more rushed than
perhaps would have been appropriate for
everybody involved
what do you think the right solution
should be now
um I'd very much like to see the home
office working
for more work to be going on to actually
stop so many people arriving on our
Shores
are you satisfied with Sue Ella
bravaman's handling of this migrant
situation
I think the situation predates Sue Ella
it's obviously been going on and growing
in magnitude for a very long time and we
do need to find better Solutions than we
have at the present time
okay well Celine Saxby we appreciate
your time this morning thanks very much
indeed for joining us
thank you
well let's talk about this issue a
little bit further our next guest has
worked under three home secretaries and
five immigration ministers in his role
as Chief Inspector of borders and
immigration he joins me now is John Vine
the UK's First Independent inspector of
borders and immigration thanks very much
indeed for talking to us here this
morning first of all I wonder if you
were able to hear Celine saxby's
concerns there MP for North Devon
concerned about a lack of communication
and migrants being moved into a hotel
that she believed was unsuitable in her
constituency what do you make of what
she had to say
well uh her last reply was saying that
um this has been building for some time
and for years we've been talking about
the increasing number of people who are
arriving in uh in Britain in small boats
and
um a growing a growing backlog of Silent
cases so it Beggars believe that the
home office hasn't been able to get
their act together to make provision
proper Provisions for the care of people
who arrive and also have well sort of
tried and tested systems in place for
redistributing people to good
accommodation and the other thing that I
find uh quite surprising going back to
the incidence of people sort of arriving
at Victoria Station in London with
nowhere to go whatever whatever the
reason for that is the home office has
an obligation to know where people are I
mean these people have arrived here made
a claim for Asylum the home the home
office should be checking their identity
when they arrive to establish exactly
who they are and they should know which
addresses they're going to and where
they can be reached and so um that's
just an aspect that seems to have been
lost in this debate
so how serious would you say the
situation was would you say there's a
real crisis in the Asylum system how bad
do you think it is
well I mean I don't really have to
comment I think uh a politician was it
was it the minister herself said that
the sister was broken I don't think I
don't think phrases like that are very
helpful actually but it seems that the
system is is completely under
overwhelmed at the moment so what we
have is you know a daily arrival of
people because law enforcement doesn't
seem to be able to stop people arriving
in boats and there are very good reasons
for that you know once people are at Sea
uh there is a real problem because
um you know you can't do a great deal
about it they're in danger because there
are floats you know in the English
Channel
but there's a massive backlog in Asylum
cases there's a hundred thousand backlog
in the processing of these Asylum claims
and I think the home office needs to
look at you know their system in place
to see whether it can be made more
efficient they can be more productive it
seems that the system is is just
creaking uh as far as I can see
yeah what what's your understanding of
why it is taking longer to Pro process
these migrants Asylum claims how hard is
it to determine which ones are genuine
which people are actually economic
migrants is it understandable that it's
taking longer yes it's always difficult
because in every migration flow there
are people who are fleeing persecution
who have got a very good case or War
zones very good case for Asylum and
there are people who are economic
migrants and there are sometimes people
who are fleeing because they are they've
been criminals in their country or
they've been a fun fighter so there's
there's a real important job for the
home office to try and discover who they
are and uh and then to decide on their
Asylum claims because most of them the
vast majority claim Asylum to remain in
the UK and every country has to do this
but we seem to be making it a
bureaucratic nightmare this has happened
before I mean when I was appointed the
Chief Inspector there was a backlog of
Asylum claims of nearly five hundred
thousand this was back in 2009. and um
you know there there were similar
problems with bureaucracy slowness
um it's um I think they they need to
look at the number of case workers they
have doing this work they need to
Quality assure uh the decisions that
they're taking and the whole process
needs to be looked at end to end
and of course it raises the issue of how
the people waiting for those answers are
being housed while they wait for the
decisions when you were independent uh
Chief Inspector you talked about
unnecessarily unpleasant treatment of
Asylum Seekers from what's been reported
in in recent days and weeks has that
changed at all the treatment of Asylum
Seekers do you think
well I'm not able to examine
um you know I'm not able to ask the home
office for data to examine and inspect
but there is an independent Chief
Inspector now and he could do that and I
think you know perhaps it's time for him
to look at this issue again I mean what
I fear is that um
staff really aren't LED well and they're
not assured that if they make difficult
decisions they'll be supported by their
senior managers that that is a gut
feeling I have about what might be that
might be happening and also I think it's
just become much more of a bureaucratic
process and we need to speed it up some
of these decisions are going to be
relatively straightforward very often
the Asylum and Refugee agencies say that
the majority I think it's about 70
approval for applicants in the UK at the
moment that's quite a different figure
from most European countries so I think
the home office needs to assure itself
that you know those decisions are being
taken uh speedily and of course there is
a cost there's a cost to the public
person having people you know waiting
for years and years and years you know
way back in 2009 people were waiting
many many years for a decision uh which
is very stressful for applicants but
also it's very costly to the public
purse
well John Vine are very interesting to
get your take on the situation we really
appreciate your time thanks so much for
talking to us here this morning
thank you
let's bring you some breaking news just
in the Northern Ireland secretary has
confirmed an Assembly Election will not
take place in December Chris Heaton
Harris says he had valuable
conversations with people across
Northern Ireland including a business
and Community Representatives he said
I've listened to their sincere concerns
about the impact and costs of an
election at this time Mr Heaton Harris
also added that he will make a statement
in Parliament to lay out the next step
so the Northern Ireland secretary there
confirming an Assembly Election there
will not take place in December more
details to follow in his statement
now Sky News has learned that FIFA has
written to all 32 Nations taking part in
the World Cup this month urging them to
ignore any political controversies and
focus exclusively on football it's
called comes amid growing criticism over
qatar's stance on same-sex relationships
it's human rights record and its
treatment of Migrant workers
well the letter from FIFA's president
Gianni Infantino says please let's now
focus on the football we know that
football doesn't live in a vacuum and we
are equally aware that there are many
challenges and difficulties of a
political nature all around the world
but please do not allow football to be
dragged into every ideological or
political battle that exists
so let's bring in our Sports presenter
Jackie Bell trout so Jackie so much
controversy over Qatar hosting at this
football tournament and interesting to
see this letter going out as well
yes absolutely it's almost like he's not
really reading the room Infantino the
FIFA president I mean a few weeks ago
Qatar did come out and say all fans are
welcome here even gay fans are welcome
for the World Cup but it remains it's
illegal to be gay in Qatar and those
laws remain they say for cultural
reasons now the captains of several
countries are going to be wearing
special armbands for the World Cup
including England Germany France it is
an armband it's a one love armband it's
it's multi-colored and it symbolizes the
fight against discrimination and the
England Captain as we've seen these
pictures Harry Kane says there's only so
much players can do but wearing the
armband on the biggest football stage
will have an impact because the
television audiences are so huge now
Denmark's shirt manufacturer Hummel do
not want to be associated with this
world cup you all struggle to see a logo
on their shirt because the shirts read
and they have made the logos red just
for this tournament they just absolutely
don't want to be associated with it
obviously
anti-lgbt laws people speaking out about
that has been the main topic but also
workers rights the number of people who
died when they were building the stadia
for this world cup what kind of
conditions did they work in all the
reports say they were awful conditions
the players do have a voice they have
been speaking out on a number of topics
on their social media their following is
huge obviously Harry Kane 13.2 million
followers on Instagram but you do know
that once the football gets started the
focus will be on football Infantino will
get his wish so now is the time to make
a point
a British man who had covered for 411
days is thought to have had the virus
longer than anyone else and survived
experts at guys in Saint Thomas's
Hospital found that he had an early
variant of the original strain so let's
talk about this a little bit more
joining me now is Dr Bharat pankanya a
an expert in infectious disease very
good morning to you
411 days at testing positive have you
ever heard anything like this before
it's not impossible it's unusual but not
impossible and by the way this is clear
this is good biology in action so this
person was immune suppressed and as a
result of being immune suppressed they
had this Persistence of infection and I
have seen many of these uh incidents in
for example TB when their immune
suppressed the infection carries on
without doing much damage to the lungs
but it can still be there so it is
possible biologically
and and there's no medicine to cure
covert per se is there so what kind of
treatment did he receive and how much
difference did that make
so he was given the whole uh our
momentum antivirals uh antibodies uh and
what has worked is that he had the
original old uh version of the virus
against which the antibodies made in the
laboratory worked and eventually he was
cured so the important Point here is if
we imagine that the uh the spikes on the
virus are the nuts and the antibodies
are the spanners then if the nuts change
shape the spanners will not fit and work
so the new variants that we have Omicron
Etc they are not attacked properly by
the uh the anti-antibodies that we have
uh made and they are therefore not
working anymore so we would have to go
back to the laboratory and make a
version of antibodies that work against
the circulating Omicron Forex example
and are treatments like this still
considered experimental or are we
getting a real idea now of how people
with persistent or serious cases can be
treated
no we're learning every day and whilst
we started off as Pioneers we know a lot
more about how to tackle this and we're
getting better and better at it so
remember we've got uh the the steroids
then we got the antiviral drugs and then
we've got the antibodies so we are
getting much much better compared to two
years ago
and what about understanding why some
people get the disease more seriously
and some get it for longer do we have a
real understanding of what it is that
that are the factors in determining that
no that's a still work in progress and
it is very important to understand that
Immunology because some people get that
infection recover end of story and some
people get that infection the infection
goes but the immune system carries on
overreacting and then you get this
incidence of what we call brain fog
tiredness and generally being unwell and
then we have to end up suppressing that
immune system so a lot to learn but
we're learning but we haven't cracked it
all together
very briefly uh former Health secretary
during the time of covid Matt Hancock is
going on I'm a celebrity quick thought
on what you make of that
and it's very disappointing because I
personally was involved in all this and
I feel uh you know nursing homes people
died uh there were this VIP contracts
their failure of PPE so much so I feel
very disappointed that Matt Hancock
seems to have put all those failings
behind him and he's off on a new career
okay we must leave it there Dr Bharat
pacmania very interesting to talk to you
this morning we're really appreciated
thank you thank you